juste revenir sur secretstory parce que
secret story ce temps 2007 benjamin
castaldi tf1 propose un renouveau dans
les émissions de télé réalité
d'enfermement avec secret-story ce
programme donc est inspiré de love story
et ses jours ils sont enfermés mais ils
ont un secret pour hisser en gros c'est
à peu près ça c'est à peu près ça ça
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'en fait on
cherchait un bon casting et après on
attribue des secret un sur un camp fait
en fait y avait un mec charismatique des
sympathiques on veut dire toi ton secret
c'est que tu es mort alors avec de
vraies stars y avait bien lancé il y
avait quelques vrais secrets mais ça
serait un peu arrangés ou norbert mêler
les secret c'est voilà j'ai j'ai une
carie petite anecdote fallait surtout
pas que les secrets de fuite pour les
candidats pour qu'ils aient les découvre
pas il ya des gens parce que c'était pas
une vraie maison c'était un préfabriqué
avec le jardin qui était ouvert et qui
balançaient des balles de tennis dans la
maison où des cheeseburgers avec les
secrets l'intérieur pour que les
candidats les vrais fort celui-là il ya
toujours des fous regardez regardez
l'explication c'est maintenant le
lancement de démonter face au coach que
vous connaîtrez enfin les 13 candidats
syfy sept garçons qui vont vit dans une
maison de 900 m² et surveiller 22 heures
sur 24 par 50 caméras et autant de
micros
de communiquer avec l'extérieur aucun
moyen d'échapper à vos yeux
et ce pendant 10 semaines ouais ouais
ouais alors est il ya un visage
emblématique de l'émission c'est ayem
qu'on embrasse wii ea games qui s'est
fait connaître pendant la saison 5 du
programme et et c'était quoi le secret
d'ayem
je sais même plus je suis en faux couple
avec daniel away et lui connaît les
séries c'est toi qui anime et décida
c'est avait connu une famine connaît
bien y aller surtout ayem enchantée
son secret bah maintenant sont des plus
belles au monde à quel accueil le fou
ayem enchantée super j'adore la came ont
chanté et enchanté ressentez juridique
ayem enchantée qui manque quelqu'un que
j'ai pas dit bonjour oui
sabrina aliens ont changé ça donne envie
enfin ça donne envie d'y être moi ça me
donne envie d'y être sont bons ils ont
sympathique et qui aurait fait de ces
catégories
je redis mon mon secret c'est ici c'est
quoi bab mon secret c'est que j'ai je ne
sais pas je n'ai pas de secret moi
j'avais eu une demande en mariage
rappelait pas avec amy entre amélie et
senna
ah ouais est ce qu'ils se sont restés
ensemble un peu après pas très longtemps
avant qu on a très longtemps mais ils
sont mariés quand même dans le bas dans
la maison bien sûr mais c'est pas un
mariage officiel annoncé patrick sont
pas vraiment marié non non non ouais
mais là tu risques oui je sais je ne
sois pas sûr je suis absolument certain
sur le mariage c'est pas très fort
mais à mes yeux c'était un peu
incroyable et on regarde ça passait non
là je crois que j'ai tant pour moi que
ça fait mal hommes tombent
j'espère
ah ah
je
ce qui tu veux devenir macha
[Musique]
et est ce que vous aimez secretstory oui
oui c'est vrai moi j'adore the motion
shot accrochages mais c'est pas ça alors
vous j'adore je vous trouve très très
bon de rire si je te jure que c'est vrai
benji est en fait franchement je m'en
fout totalement de leur série et de
allez voir ce que vous est de savoir si
l'équipe est choquée c'est dans ce
programme on a aussi pu découvrir une
séquence très très drôle c'est un
candidat qui visiblement n'a pas bien
compris les consignes de la voix
regardez pour sabrina le micro 8h envie
de prendre son final à bertoua la
prenant par lucky nombre avec le prix
accordé par le biais de la cachette par
le pied mais non voilà d'où l'expression
[Applaudissements]
on embrasse d'ailleurs si tu nous
regardes et voilà depuis la savoie reste
un mois y avait une page vous le dis je
kiffais une meuf dans secret story
à l'époque qui fait hacker niveau cindy
lopes et je m'en rappelle elle avait eu
le malheur de prendre sa douche tout nu
ah ouais ouais ce qui avait choqué les
autres candidats et moi aussi j'étais
choqué je t'ai même délit choqué
[Rires]
[Musique]
normal petite coquine que tu veux toi et
tes poumons à la page sombre dessein
ouais mais là il ya une séquence comme
ça s'est terminé à l'économie non mais
géraldine c'est un truc non mais c'est
dingue sur têt cmt avoir ça c'est un sur
tf1 c'était ça elles abattront cuba
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire c'est que la sceptique tout
aujourd'hui est ce que c'était vraiment
un traumatisme est ce que c'est vraiment
une régression chypre et d'accuser moi
je suis traumatisé à vous étiez
traumatique voir si à l'époque on
n'était pas du tout bas on a vu cette
séquence
non mais ce qu on venait maintenant mais
c'est incroyable cette séquence avec le
religieux alors là son radar doit
arrêter métier bien dans les dents dans
les douches après temps